Trish is with us in Richmond Virginia hi
Trish welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
thanks Dave
I am recently separated from my husband
we had a business together that has
about three hundred fifty thousand
dollars cash
we have two properties two houses I'm
living in the family home which is very
expensive to be in - 2316 dollars how
much I paid for that mortgage I take
home between my salary and support 5,200
dollars a month and my husband wants me
to I had to leave because he was
verbally abusive husband wants me to
stay in the house so that the equity can
build over the years and that would be
my half in our settlement and I'm
feeling somewhat overwhelmed with the
payment on this mortgage I'm torn
because I'd like to stay in the house
it's where my kids are comfortable and
how long have you been married 21 years
okay and you do not work in the business
I helped a little in the last couple
years your job that you're telling me
about is not done at the business you
have a different job yes I have a
different job you make fifty two hundred
dollars a month and you have a twenty
two hundred dollar mortgage
what is the home worth probably about
four hundred and fifty thousand and what
is owed against it 290 mm okay so
there's 150 there and 350 over in the
business and so there's about five
hundred thousand so you're half of all
of this about a quarter million right
yes that sound about right to you that
and the second property the second
property probably has I don't know fifty
thousand and equity in that okay all
right cool all right so how old are your
children
I have a 20 year old an 18 year old and
a 14 year old okay let me tell you what
I'm hearing and you tell me if I'm wrong
okay okay
this guy has verbally told you what to
do so long you got used to being told
what to do and now he's trying to tell
you what to do again and so my reaction
as your older ugly brother is I don't
care what he wants okay how's that sound
I'm getting stronger and it sounds more
like what I would say now versus what I
would have said five months ago all I
care about is your future in these kids
future Baba can figure his deal out what
he desires is no longer on the table he
lost that right when he verbally abused
his wife for 21 years if I take money
out of it don't drive past that don't
drive past that you just drove off and
left that on the curb we got to settle
that are you okay with not caring what
he thinks about this settlement I want
you to settle it for the good of you and
the kids period is that okay with you
yeah okay good because I think okay
you're making $60,000 a year you don't
need a $2,200 a month payment kiddo so
if he wants something I'd sell the house
that's all yeah because the house is no
longer the house is not a blessing to
the future you and that's always a
burden it needs a lot of repairs it's on
ten acres and I'm spending my time
chainsawing trees and sell this thing
sell this thing yeah I get free so
here's the deal if you walk away with
$250,000 cash in your pocket because you
get your half of the cash from this and
your half of the cash out of the
business I think you can probably figure
out a place to live that's much more
conducive to the future you okay does
that make sense to you thank you yes yes
the problem a divorce turns a marriage
into a business transaction and in spite
of all the emotions this by the 21 years
of history and in spite of the kids
feelings which they're really hurting to
we've got to do what's smart and wise
for you and those children in the future
not the past
and that might mean a change in school
system it might it definitely means a
different place to live even if it's
within that same school system because
this you keeping this house doesn't fit
in your equation County that wouldn't
necessarily be the one that I would
choose to stay and does it make sense to
buy a house for three years to stay in
the same County for the school system
and then move again and okay I'm okay if
you rent for a little while especially
while you while you heal and just be
very very careful don't let this in this
dig you get out of this deal get away
from you during that time no I I can be
very careful I'm doing I'm diligent now
I'm intentional and I've got every
dollar and I am currently I'm not making
I'm living above my means and that feels
very scary to me yeah well because you
have a house payment that's 50% of your
take-home pay yes with duct tape and
chainsaws there's no no this sounds fun
to me I want to set you free okay thank
you god bless you darling you're gonna
be all right I'm sorry you guys are
going through this it's horrible thing
horrible hurtful thing but you're gonna
be okay you're gonna be okay you got a
future here the numbers here are okay
it's just a broken heart that's part of
the issue
this is the Dave Ramsey chef